I was hoping you were home
okay Audrey you really freaked us out in
descendants three we know you lost your
shot at the crown not to mention your
boyfriend but don't worry you don't have
to be the queen of mean to get what you
want
do you think we speak for everyone when
we say we're glad you put down that
scepter but we have to be honest
you're evil look was a wicked cool
before you judge Audrey there are some
things you need to know about her she's
not your typical villain kid she's a
good princess gone bad gone good again
but here's what nobody realizes about
Audrey in descendants three keep
watching to find out who she's teaming
up with after d3 Audrey didn't start out
as evil sure she was a little full of
herself and yes she thought Ben was her
property we're not even sure she loved
Ben or if she was dating him so she
could just wool auradon I was princess
girlfriend on the fast track to becoming
his wife in the Queen Audrey was clearly
better about Mouse stealing everything
she ever wanted but she shocked everyone
when she stole Maleficent sceptre and
turned into the queen of mean how did
this happen let's start at the beginning
and piece this thing together at the
beginning of the movie Audrey wasn't
planning on creating a sleep spell that
knocked out all the word on she had just
returned from the salon rested and fresh
with a fabulous new makeover you could
see the look of complete and total shock
on her face when Ben proposed - mal we
watched Audrey's dream of being the
queen of auradon shatter like a glass
slipper
when Audrey broke into the museum she
didn't intend to go full evil she just
wanted to steal the crown did you notice
that she didn't even put the crown on
her head until after she transformed
into evil Audrey she was about to throw
it away but then the scepter hypnotized
her the same way Maleficent hypnotized
Sleeping Beauty some people thought that
Audrey caused the guard at the front of
the museum to fall asleep but what if it
was the scepter well if it's in scepter
beckoned Audrey into the museum and
lured her into going full
the scepter wanted her to take control
of it the magic in that staff was too
much for Audrey to resist
she was under an evil spell which caused
her to cast many additional evil curses
so was it all Audrey's fault
keep watching to find out when Ben and
mal got engaged Audrey didn't only lose
out on the crown she also lost her first
love then was the only boy she's ever
had eyes for she had her future with him
all planned out we know that mal didn't
mean to do it but she took it all away
from Audrey it seemed that Audrey had
everything a princess could one but did
she truly love Ben Audrey was betrothed
to Ben since she was just a little girl
perhaps her grandmother convinced her to
love Ben despite what she really wanted
in Audrey's room there are pictures of
her and then going all the way back to
preschool Audrey was too young to be
able to choose a partner for herself
back then those photos were staged by
Audrey's grandmother who knows if Audrey
would have chosen Ben to be her
boyfriend if she had a choice from the
beginning so who would she choose if it
were up to her we'll get into that a
little bit later it's obvious that
Audrey only wants to make her
grandmother proud in fact every action
Audrey takes in The Descendants movies
is tied to her need to please her Grammy
so when Audrey hears her grandmother's
fighting words of disapproval after mal
and Ben's engagement it cuts her to her
core all she ever wanted was to make her
granny proud our family stutters gone
Queen Leah's expectations of Audrey were
impossible to achieve
Audrey reached her breaking point when
she learned she would never be the queen
of auradon
that's when she crowned herself the
queen of mean underneath all of that
pink hair and distressed leather was
just a little girl who needed the
unconditional love and approval of her
grandmother instead her grandmother
slapped her with that cruel comment that
Audrey's mother could hold on to a
prince in her sleep now we see where
Audrey learned to be so mean now here's
the really mind-blowing thing that
nobody gets about Audrey if it wasn't
for her the barrier would have never
been opened
Audrey's evil deeds became the catalyst
for change in auradon allow us to
explain before Audrey stole the crown
and the
after another villain was stirring up
trouble that's right we're talking about
Hades after he pushed his way through
the barrier and almost stole all of
Mel's powers
everyone in auradon was terrified they
wanted to close the barrier for good and
it was all mouths idea which was a total
whoa moment for fans I think that we
have to close barrier forever
if Audrey hadn't stolen the crown and
scepter put asleep and stones fell on
everyone and turned Ben into a beast now
would have learned nothing
instead mal came to realize that there
is both good and evil in every one that
realization is what made mal decide to
take down the barrier for good so thanks
Audrey thankfully when Audrey woke from
her deep sleep she was back to her old
self again alas she was still without a
prince on her arm but don't feel bad for
her from the sparks flying between
Audrey and Harry we think the pirate's
life might be right for Audrey so what's
your verdict is Audrey mean or
misunderstood sound off in the comments
[Music]
we were so excited when you got a chance
to go to Oregon dizzy we just knew that
Evie had to pick you after all you are
practically her little sister I can't
believe I get to live with you in your
very own job you might have spent most
of descendants three under a sleeping
spell but there is a lot more to you
than meets the eye and we are here to
clear up all the reasons you're such an
awesome character
dizzy Germain is one of the newest vks
in Oregon
check out these theories and connections
that no one realized about dizzy family
business when we first meet dizzy in
descendants - she works in her
grandmother salon we don't meet lady
tremaine until the third movie but she
seems to treat dizzy a lot like she
treated Cinderella dizzy is responsible
for doing all the cleaning and she gets
yelled at - but a relationship with her
grandmother is way more complicated than
that we don't get to see a lot of
interaction between them but here's what
we know from descendants three it seems
like Lady Tremaine is the main parental
figure - did the
Dizzy's mah mistress Allah and her aunt
is Anastasia but we never see
Cinderella's two wicked stepsisters when
dizzy is ready to leave the aisle her
mom and aunt are nowhere to be seen but
her grandmother is there to say goodbye
to her lady tremaine is super strict but
dizzy loves her she gives her a big hug
this family obviously doesn't like to
show affection
lady tremaine is totally taken aback by
the gesture their relationship may not
be perfect but there is definitely love
there but why don't we see Drizella well
let's be honest
Drizella is not cut out to raise a kid
don't you remember how childish and
awful she was in Cinderella Lady
Tremaine has raised two daughters so
she's the obvious choice when it comes
to raising dizzy dizzy is also related
to someone from Oregon they don't
mention this in the movie so you might
not have noticed but dizzy is related to
Chad charming Dizzy's mom Drizella was
the stepsister of Cinderella chad is the
son of prince charming and Cinderella
that means that Chad and dizzy are
cousins
well technically their step cousins but
there are lots of blended families that
don't make that distinction does he acts
more like the sweet Cinderella we know
and love and Chad is so spoiled he acts
more like Drizella did these two should
have switched parents we bet that dizzy
and Chad will connect and Cinderella
will be the awesome aunt that dizzy
deserves the next Eevee I would like to
begin with the granddaughter of Lady
Tremaine each of the core four got to
pick the next generation of vks to come
to auradon our original villain kids are
just about done with school
they picked kids that really resonated
with them J and Carlos picked squeaky
and squirmy because no one expected much
from those boys no one ever expected
much from Carlos and J either but they
believed in the Smee twins now picked
Celia because she is the baddest kid on
the Isle and Evie picked Izzie because
they're so similar they're definitely
the sweetest of the villain kids they
see the good in people and being mean
just doesn't come naturally to them Suzy
is also a fashionista
like Edie Edie brought her fashion
design skills to ward on Perez dizzy
will bring her awesome salon skills we
expect to see some awesome hairstyles at
the school now no magic needed she's
also talented at making accessories like
Evie's tiara from descendants - Evie
respects Dizzy's talents we think these
two will end up in business together
after dizzy graduate
Evie love's dizzy they're just like
sisters did these mom got to grow up
with a sister but dizzy is an only child
and she didn't get a lot of affection at
home but she did from Evie Evie was the
person who believed in dizzy she was
always quick to hug her and encourage
her
Evie wanted dizzy in auradon because she
knows she belongs there she's smart and
kind and talented and now dizzy can be
the cool loving older sister to this me
twins and other decays why dizzy didn't
fight after meeting dizzy in the second
movie we expected her to have a much
bigger role in descendants 3 but we
really didn't get to see too much of her
smell tells her to stay with the twins
dizzy squeaky and squirmy all fall under
Audrey's sleeping spell
so why didn't dizzy fight she might be
like Evie in a lot of ways but there is
one important difference
dizzy doesn't know how to fight most of
the villain kids learned how to fight
from their parents but Dizzy's family
wasn't particularly skilled in combat or
Savion magic dizzy didn't have anyone
tough to show her the ropes
if dizzy had gone to the aisle with
mousy Leah and the rest she wouldn't
have fallen under the sleeping spell but
she would have been in way more danger
does he stay here to take care of the
twins we'll be right back and everything
will be just fine
mal and Evie wanted to protect her and
Disney wasn't even upset about it you
don't have to be tough to be a VK dizzy
just knows that she has her strengths
she's responsible and caring still part
of us wishes that dizzy had been a more
prominent figure in descendants 3 do you
think Disney made the right choice by
staying in auradon or could she have
helped the BK's throughout their quest
tell us in the comments and be sure to
tell us what you love about dizzy while
you're at it
o Jafar you did an amazing job at
raising J sure you turned him into a
master thief but unlike the rest of the
bee case you and Jay had a
a strong relationship he stole things to
help you run your shop and he rubbed
every lamp you came across just in case
it was the one you were searching for J
is always there for his friends and he's
got family values in the bag so we guess
what we're trying to say is thank you
for giving us Jay Jay has changed a lot
throughout the descendants franchise but
we didn't realize just how much he had
evolved until we watched descendants 3
here are 10 things nobody realizes about
Jay when we first meet Jay it didn't
take us long to find out that he had
sticky fingers Jay could shake your hand
and swipe your wallet and you'd be none
the wiser Jay continued to steal stuff
when he first came over to our Adan but
it didn't take long for his fingers to
lose their grip we couldn't believe our
eyes when Jay stopped Harry from
stealing in a case wallet in his Sinan's
3 wow he sure has come a long way Jay
loves his freedom and everything that
comes with it
he plans to travel and embark on more
adventures than he can count although
it's hard to believe Jay is the only
single VK out of the original core for
evey has dug now has been and Carlos has
Jane and when he comes today he's got
adventure on the brain Jay doesn't seem
to mind the single life he looks happy
to be on his own in descendents 3 but
Jay is never alone because his fellow
bk's have quickly become his family and
J values family above all else when the
V case were given the task of choosing a
recruit Jay Chou's to pair up with
Carlos and pick the Smee twins Jay
wanted to keep the twins together no
matter what he knows how important it is
to be surrounded by family which is why
he would never separate squeaky and
squirmy and no way we're splitting up
the twins so get over here squirmy come
on the wild Jay may be content with
hanging out with the fam there is one
person he didn't bother mentioning
throughout the film and that's Lonnie
most of us thought that Jay and Lonnie
would be an item by descendants three
because well they totally hit it off in
d2 but for some strange reason Jay
remains single throughout the three cool
and never once mentions his could have
been girlfriend we wonder what happened
between these two although we don't get
the full story we do know that Lonnie is
spending
her time with her swords and shields
team and since Jay loves sports he would
never stop her from following her
passions Jays real passion on the other
hand is playing tore knee
he's the tourney team's star player and
he proudly wears number eight on his
back did you guys notice how Jay usually
sports an embroidered Cobra on his fact
he loves to represent afar and he does
this on the tour knee field to his
number eight it's easily switched out
for a cobra mimicking the infinity sign
whereas Carlos wants to become a
veterinarian Jay wants to become a
professional Tour knee player Jay's
dream is to go pro and become a torna
coach once he's done playing the field
so while mal and Ben will be busy
brewing over our Don and the aisle Jay
will be touring the world and playing
his favorite sport it takes a lot of
guts to go after our dreams the Jay
knows what he wants and he's not afraid
to go after it and luckily for our Don
Jace one of the bravest V Ches of all
time this was proven in d3 when Hades
managed to sneak his head and arm out of
the barrier Jay was the first one to
charge Hades his bravery is undeniable
but unfortunately it resulted in him
being the first one to get blasted by
Hades
luckily mouths dad didn't actually hurt
anyone
J has always been brave which makes us
wonder if this is something his father
taught him he might have noticed how J
is the only VK out of the core for to
have a single father instead of a single
mother but the scale tipped in
descendants three when Hades was
revealed as Mal's dad
now both mal and J have father figures
in their lives but who could Jay's
mother be if you have any theories
comment them down below some people
believe that Jays mom was a pirate and
the reason behind this assumption makes
sense in return to the Isle of the Lost
Jay gets approached to join Captain
Hook's pirate crew
however Jay refuses and continues to
help his father run his shop it would
make sense for Jays mom to be a pirate
since he was approached by Captain Hook
but in the end Jay ended up being close
friends with uma hairy and Gil so he
might very well have the C coursing
through his veins I want to get a kick
out of a very bish we were happy to see
Jay hit it off with Gil because well Jay
seemed to be a little lonely in
descendents 3 while Jay had plenty of
friends they were all in relationships
and making future plans without him so
finding a friend like Gil was super
important Jay looks so excited when he
started bonding with Gil and now the
boys have plans to travel the world for
the entire year you know what will be
fun to go rafting in a jungle river find
a lot of civilization or maybe a penguin
we wish we could watch their adventures
on the small screen what do you say you
me go exploring I'll do a gap year
jungles or icebergs both so did you guys
notice anything else about Jay and
descendants 3 sound off in the comments
section on the plus side it's been the
longest birthday I've ever had
Real Talk Jane do you have any idea how
awesome you are
Minnie fancy you as the unsung hero of
descendants three Carlos was lucky to be
with a smart go-getter like you if only
you could see what the rest of the world
sees you are obsessed with magic but the
truth is you are magic and we love to
watch you shine so own it girl
there is one descendant who is more than
she appears to be and one villain kids
saw that before everyone else that's why
he fell hopelessly in love with her
there are so many things about Jane that
nobody realizes watch until the end to
find out what secret magical powers Jane
possesses do you guys remember when Jane
stepped into her power and descendants -
she was a boss in charge of the entire
cotillion and it was epic she definitely
came a long way since her days of
following Audrey around in the first
Descendants movie but Jane's journey
reveals something you may have missed
about the fairy godmothers daughter
let's start at the beginning Jane
started out as a shy sweet little
auradon gal who was afraid of the
villain kids from the Isle that's okay
don't mind me as you were
Jane was fascinated with magic even
though her mother wouldn't let her
anywhere near it Jane had trouble
figuring out who she truly was in the
first movie that's why she helped Audrey
bully now she had no self-confidence
this lack of self-esteem cost her to
only see her value in her appearance but
we all know now that there is so much
more to her than that once Jane slowly
started to accept the BK she started to
accept herself as well becoming friends
with Malin or crew helped Jane to see
that it's not just about your outside
appearance it's what's inside your heart
that counts that's when she really takes
the lead in descendants
- Jane steps into the leadership role in
do - with the planning of the cotillion
she is much more outgoing and happy this
makes her irresistible to Carlos but
along with the newfound confidence comes
a bit of cluelessness she gets frazzled
easily during the planning of the big
celebration and she's totally oblivious
to Carlos having a crush on her when he
tries to ask her out he has to explain
over and over again what he means
would you be my date for cotillion
carlos is so happy when she finally says
yes and let's not forget jean is the one
who tried to stop Ana Numa from getting
together by unveiling Ben's gift for Mau
at the cotillion by accepting the
villain kid she started accepting
herself as well but Jane's
transformation in d3 was the most
surprising one of all keep watching to
find out more about her secret powers in
d3 Jane doesn't know why Carlos misses
her birthday celebration but even then
she still believes in Carlos and sure
Jane can be a bit naive sometimes but
she's still outsmarts Audrey she jumps
into the enchanted lake to avoid
succumbing to Audrey sleep spell Jane
calls to warn Ben and also tries to call
her mom so she could get her wand and
put a stop to the madness
she takes action rather than staying on
the sidelines and she saves the day
again when she sprays Ben with water
from the enchanted lake to turn him back
from the Beast to man where did this
Jane come from she just did what needed
to be done she didn't ask for permission
from anyone
Jane has come a long way since the first
descendants movie and can we talk about
what a cute couple Jane and Carlos are
even when she thought Carlos forgot her
birthday all she cared about was if he
was alright and he was so happy to see
her that birthday gift
Carlos got for Jane was perfect jar
loaves forever it broke our hearts when
Jane saw that her mom was turned to
stone but this is the biggest moment
when we see Jane's true self shine she
is now the one reassuring and rescuing
her mother she has to rely on the very
magic that her mother forbade her to use
not that long ago
Jane represents the heart of the movie
she is kind brave and in charge the old
Jane would have crumbled under this kind
of pressure but this new and improved
Jane finally understands the impact she
can have on auradon here's the truth
about Jane that nobody realizes Jane
knows just how strong and mighty the
power of love can be she knows that you
can change an entire kingdom by
connecting with the person right in
front of you
took the time and effort to encourage
every person she met and when her mom
was turned back into her human self Jane
was there to comfort her she told her
mom that it's okay this heart-to-heart
connection that Jane fosters between
herself and others makes her the unsung
hero of The Descendants movies mal and
Audrey went through some major
transformations throughout the
descendance movies but Jane also grew
and changed significantly she didn't
understand that she had power without
magic all along but by the end of d3 she
notes that her magical powers are
leadership and compassion in the future
we can see our becoming a great
ambassador for auradon sitting right
next to mal and then on the throne all
leaders must have courage and compassion
and that is why Jane is the queen of
compassion do you think Jane is the
unsung hero of descendant 3 if so leave
a star emoji down below if you disagree
tell us who you think the real hero of
descendants three is in the comments
thank you for watching hit that
subscribe button and notification Bell
to be the first to know when we post a
new video and don't forget to give us a
big thumbs up we'll see you later
[Music]